hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
and let's say that you're faced with a
difficult decision to make let's say
you're wondering whether you should you
know
watch a basketball game on tv or listen
to an old episode of the mindscape
podcast
and you think about it you weigh the
different factors you come to a decision
and then someone asks you why did you
make the decision
that you made and you would offer some
explanation some reason you know
i want this i value that and i made the
decision based on these
calculations so today's guest robert
sapolsky
is here to tell you that you're wrong no
matter what
you gave as explanations almost no
matter what i mean maybe you're exactly
right but
more likely you have simplified things
and rationalized
quite a bit robert zapolsky is a
neuroscientist a neuroendocrinologist i
believe is the technical term
uh also studies other aspects of biology
psychology anthropology primatology
uh and is a very well-known researcher
in the field of
human and broader primate behavior the
author of a book just a couple years ago
called behave the biology of humans at
our best
and worst and the thing that he tackles
in this book it's one of those books
every single reviewer
refers to it as magisterial which is a
way of saying that it's both long
and good and the topic that he tackles
is why do we behave
in the ways that we do and in particular
why do we make the decisions that lead
us
to behave in the ways we do and his
thesis more or less is that there's no
one answer
to that question there's no single thing
that explains why we do it's a
complicated set of factors
from things that are operating on time
scales of less than a second
to things that are operating on time
scales of thousands or millions of years
and what we do is we rationalize we
invent reasons that may have some
relationship
to the actual reasons that exist but
they're not exactly
the same reasons so what we're going to
do in today's podcast is talk about all
of that it will
touch on common mindscape themes like
free will and plasticity of the brain
and what you can do with it and also the
ability of humans
to think about the future in different
ways and also we keep coming back to the
question of
what good this knowledge is you know if
you really understand
what's going on in all the different
parts of your brain
and your genome and your experience that
go into making a decision
does that help you make better decisions
in some definition of the word
better and at the end we decide that you
should buy
robert zubowski's books although to be
fair
that was my idea not his uh to say that
i'm of the opinion
that knowing more about what's really
going on in our brains and our behavior
helps us understand what we should do as
well as what we do do
maybe it'll help you let's see and let's
[Music]
go
robert sapolsky welcome to the mindscape
podcast oh thanks for having me on so
you've written this wonderful book
called behave studying how uh why we
behave why we do
the things we do and i think maybe for
fun it would be good to start rather
than with
the true reasons for why we behave the
way we do surely
everyone has a straw man idea in their
head right people must
think they know why we behave the way we
do so
what is the wrong idea that you're sort
of trying to fix that we all have in our
minds
well basically that there's any
uh discipline which is this which is it
which is the the holy grail which is the
the code of codes that explains
everything um and this comes in
different flavors depending on what kind
of scientist you are
what kind of consumer of science either
everything in the world is explained by
genes right
where everything in the world is
explained by brain chemistry or
by hormones or by and
you know in all these cases you get a
very narrow
interdisciplinary view as to
what the behavior is about and where
does it come from
and the song and dance that i just spent
endless number of pages on in the book
is you got to incorporate all the
different influences that
will occur before behavior starting
what's going on in your brain one second
before
up to what sort of evolutionary forces
have been playing out in the last
million years
because they're all pertinent to why we
do what we do
well it raises an interesting
philosophical question i don't know how
familiar you are with the
philosophy literature that is now bled
over into sort of computer science and
social sciences about causality
and bayesian networks and all this stuff
but what do you
mean by what causes something like this
or what is the reason why do you do you
personally have to worry about that
question
um on some level although
you know rather than like bayesian stuff
absolutely terrifies me and
sort of everything that comes with it
unfortunately i can figure out how to
bypass it as to what actually
counts as causal um because what i think
the most important thing
to come out of studying the biology of
our behavior
is not highfalutin debates about the
nature of causality
it's getting people to stop thinking
that
people are the causes in a conscious
willful agent-filled way that people are
responsible for their behavior
right well this is something this is
another philosophical issue that i'm
sure we will get into
down the road here but the free will
issue right and something we've talked
about on the podcast quite a bit
um and yeah i think hopefully none of us
in the room or at least presumably none
of us in the room here are
uh believers in libertarian free will
and the idea that there's some spirit
inside us that is not beholden to the
laws of nature whatsoever
but but many of us many of my best
friends including myself are
compatibilists about free will we think
that it's a
useful way to think about human agents
right making decisions
so but you sound like i think i get the
idea from your book that you're
more on the other side that you're
you're you want to dismantle the idea
that we should think of people
as agents responsible for their actions
yep i i think i
thus count as a hard incompatible list
as the label goes um
you know there's kind of a sense that it
seems self-evident
from my perspective if you spend enough
decades
studying enough different ways in which
our brain and behavior are influenced by
stuff we had no control over that put
all those pieces together and
free will is just what we call the
biology that hasn't been discovered yet
so you think that as we understand more
and more about the biology the idea of
some room left for
human free will will just uh go away
yeah basically because if you look at i
don't know the last 500 years of
knowledge
that's been a theme over and over and in
some ways
the last half millennium what biology
and behavior is mostly consisted of
is people saying oh i had no idea
that had something to do with why that
behavior happens
and what has occurred in the process is
um if there is free will it's getting
crammed into smaller and smaller places
and you know if i'm trying to be a good
house guest and
not a jerk or whatever i can usually
leave it there and say
you know you want to have some free will
go for it if you want to cite free will
as to why you
flossed your upper teeth this morning
before your lower teeth
be happy go for it but in substantive
ways
all that science has spent centuries
doing
is teaching us oh that's actually a
biological phenomenon
that's actually stuff out of our control
that's actually stuff
that was sculpted by issues that were
sheer
histories of luck or bad luck all we are
is the sum nothing more or less of
what our biology and its interactions
with environment have been
right which is the perfect segue clearly
you've done this before
uh into talking about what the reasons
are that our biology
has become that way and in the book you
have this um
device of sort of going backward in time
right of looking at things that work on
very short time scales to affect our
behavior and then
going further and further into the past
uh to look at other things that affect
our behavior and i'll confess
i was not able to do any better than
that so i figure we can just sort of
rehearse uh that kind of explanation and
that should
give us an opportunity to cover lots of
interesting ground so
what is going on in the brain
immediately like how should we think
about
our our very quick reactions our
subconscious our system one kind of
behavior
great well one of the things we've
learned and you know we could be talking
about a lot of different domains of
behavior here but
the two that interest me are the ones
that would be labeled our
best behaviors and our worst ones um
because that's like this hugely
challenging thing about us as a species
we are simultaneously the most miserably
violent species on earth
while we are also the most cooperative
and the most altruistic in the and
how do you balance those two and how do
you make sense of them and especially
how do you make sense of the fact that
the same exact behavior
can count as wonderfully pro-social in
one setting
and like wildly anti-social in another
now as we begin to look at that like
somebody does one of these behaviors
and often when we say why did that
happen
why did that person do that just now um
the first pass is we're asking
a neurobiological question what went on
in that person's brain
a second ago a minute ago that
caused those muscles to get a command to
pull that trigger or put your hand
empathically on somebody else's
or whatever the behavior was and what we
now know is there's all sorts of
outposts in the brain you know the usual
suspects
frontal cortex amygdala anterior
cingulate ventral tegmentum insulin
cortex
if these are not familiar yeah don't
panic they're not relevant
um but mainly there's areas in the brain
that are really central to us
deciding what counts as the right thing
to do
and system one versus system two what we
see
over and over is the elements that go
into us making those decisions
the percentage of which the percentage
of those
that we are conscious of and we believe
that we were deliberating between
choices that we had the option to choose
is tiny
right instead we are being run by
subterranean neurobiological forces in
our brain
and you know the classic way of
demonstrating that is you ask somebody
to
write down what their favorite detergent
is and
people are more likely to say tide if
they've just read a paragraph about the
ocean
and when you ask them why they don't say
because i just read a paragraph about
the ocean
they're gonna confabulate some
supposedly rational reason why
post hoc implicit unconscious stuff
brought them to the point
and when we look at us and our
sort of most impactful moments people
spend an awful long time
thinking about like moral decision
making
do we think our way to our decisions or
do we feel our way
and for a long time thinking our way was
the dominant model because that seemed
oh so much more brainy than like being
some
lizard going about its actions um
what has become clear is an awful lot of
the time
we are feeling our way to our moral
decisions
and we're coming up with justifications
afterward for why that makes perfect
sense
what we just did and is there some clean
distinction between
those decisions that are more cognitive
i mean when we
when we buy a house i'm sure there's
some emotional things that come into it
and some rational things that come into
it
how well do we understand that well
depends on what level you're looking at
if you're sticking somebody in a brain
scanner
you could see that if they give them a
decision to make about
something totally like soulless and
bloodless and cold or whatever
um do you want to open up this can of
vegetables or that kind of vegetables
you're just activating some not very
exciting cortical regions
okay when you were now making a decision
of like
do you give this person the death
penalty or not for this unspeakable
thing that they did
you're now activating the cortex but
you're also activating
emotional parts of the brain the limbic
system
but the thing that is most like
important about that
is you can tell the decision someone is
going to make
by looking at the readout for their
limbic emotional brain before you get a
readout from the cortex it's a better
predictor
that's more likely when you're trying to
figure out
if somebody is guilty or not and this
has been done with brain imaging studies
with mock jurors
you're using your cortex to decide on
innocence or guilt
when you're deciding how much to punish
them it's all the limbic system
and so it's it's both that there's a lot
of unconscious stuff going on
below the surface but also that we sort
of shamelessly rationalize
it into a more um cognitive
exposure explanation after the fact
exactly and
one of the best ways of spotting when
that's happening
is when we're not yet able to do the job
of rationalizing when you've got
somebody sitting there
and they say you know i i can't quite
put my finger on it i can't tell you why
exactly
but when those people do that thing
that's different from what we do
it's wrong wrong wrong and in fact it's
morally wrong
i can't tell you why but it's wrong
trust me like
that is your like red light's going off
saying
this is somebody who was running
implicitly on
non-conscious decision making about
really consequential stuff
and they haven't gotten there yet in
their cognitive rationalizations to say
aha i just thought of it this is why
when they do that it's totally
wrong because it's going to teach our
kids bad values because it's the same
thing they did to our ancestors in the
battle whatever
in 1428 because ah
that's the justification i've just come
up with for
the fact that i'm making those decisions
predominantly emotionally and
implicitly and there's a couple
questions that immediately arise one is
do we have some sort of evolutionary
explanation for where all these
different systems come from do they do
they serve good purposes
yeah and this is where you could easily
get into a debate
between the the mr spock types and the
new age you know hot tub
to sort of contemplating their navels as
to
like wouldn't it be a so much better
world if all we did was make decisions
based on rationality
would say the mr spock types and
wouldn't it be a so much better world if
we made our decisions
based on feelings and feelings for our
fellow humans
say the hot tub folks and what you see
is
like big unradical surprise
uh you need both and when you get people
who have damage
to parts of the brain that are much more
about one component or the other
um you get totally different
abnormalities
but you sure get abnormal behavior in
both cases
everyone wants to keep their home and
family safe whether it's from a break-in
a fire flood or a medical emergency
simply safe home security delivers
award-winning 24 7 protection
with simply safe you don't just get an
arsenal of cameras and sensors
you get the best professional monitors
in the business they've got your back
day and night
ready to send police fire or emts when
you need them most
straight to your door i have one on
order i confess i don't have mine yet
but what i like about it is that it's
supposed to be very simple to set up
even for a theoretical physicist like
myself
simply safe has an arsenal of sensors
and cameras that protect every inch of
your home
the setup takes 30 minutes super easy
and then simply saves professionals take
over
monitoring your home and ready to send
help the moment there's an alarm
plus with simply safe there's no
long-term contract no hidden fees and
installation costs
so right now mindscape listeners get a
free home security camera
when you purchase a simply saved system
at simplisafe.commindscape
you also get a 60-day risk-free trial so
there's nothing to lose
visit simplysafe.com mindscape for your
free security camera today
that's simply safe simpl
dot com slash mindscape
you know i did have paul bloom on the
podcast uh
he wrote this wonderful book called
against empathy but
yeah i took the other side and i take it
that uh his idea was that
if you put too much emphasis on empathy
you're sort of
intentionally or at least consciously
um giving rain to those
more emotional systems underground
rather than
the cognitive rational part of your
brain and therefore we should sort of
uh give more emphasis to the rational
part of our deliberation rather than our
empathy do you where do you come down on
that
um well i think his stuff is wonderful
and like that book is great
um i would not so much say that he is
voting for
rationality in moral decision making as
much as he's being a cautionary voice
saying let's go let's not get too
carried away with all the bandwagon
excitement about
empathy where that's just like the
buzzword on everyone's lips
um because as he very rightly points out
there's a temptation to decide that
empathy
is a virtue in and of itself all you
have to do is feel badly for the person
and that's the danger of thinking
empathy is so wonderful
and the key to a much more peaceful plan
and all of that
and the key issue is not whether you are
empathically feeling somebody else's
pain and the nuances of that
but whether that empathy actually gets
translated into doing something into a
compassionate
act and the thing that he's good at
pointing out
is in a lot of circumstances not only
does
empathy not lead you to actually acting
upon it doing the right thing
when that's scary or brave or whatever
um but that certain types of empathy
make it even less likely
that you're going to do something about
it because you're so consumed
with the pain of you feeling that other
person's pain
well and one point he seems to make very
effectively is that
if we're not very good at empathy uh we
are empathic for people like ourselves
right like in the same position in the
same race
etc um and you sort of make similar
points in your book and and
you do use the phrase or the the label
the anterior cingulate
uh as as part of the brain that is
responsible for these decisions
yeah and here's here's one of these like
all-time depressing findings
anterior cingulate obscure but totally
cool part of the brain
it's got something to do with empathy
and pain
pokes your your finger gets poked with a
needle while you're in a brain scanner
your anterior cingulate activates ouch
now instead watch the finger if your
loved one gets poked with a needle
anterior cingulate activates you are
literally as far as those neurons are
concerned feeling that person's pain
as purely as if it's your own but where
the depressing stuff comes in
is show people film clips of say
somebody's hand being poked with a
needle
and if that hand has a different skin
color from your own
on the average there's less activation
of the anterior cingulate
in other words you know not everyone's
pain is equal
and we bring all sorts of biases that
are the outcome of everything that have
brought us to that moment
many of which we have no conscious
awareness of and most of which we have
no conscious control over
right i mean my my counter argument and
i'm curious to see what you think about
this was simply that
very often when we think we're being
rational
we're just being empathic in a bad way
we're sort of not recognizing
the pain or the experience of people who
are very
unlike ourselves so rather than saying
don't listen to your empathy
our the the slogan should be get more
rational empathy in some sense is that
even a reasonable
aspiration um absolutely or the way
i mean that that's addressing one of the
problems with
ooh empathy is all you need is empathy
um which is that you were bringing your
own filters as to whose pain counts for
more
and people who are familiar people who
are local
people whose pains are like ones that
you've experienced so
that's where rational empathy helps the
other component where
empathy is not enough is one that calls
for what i would think of as
detached empathy one of the problems
with empathy of feeling somebody else's
pain
is the pain is painful whether it's like
your pain
or their pain that you're now feeling
and
if the empathic pain is severe enough
the logical thing is to say i can't take
this anymore and i'm getting out of here
i'm going to turn the page i'm going to
decide it's not really my problem i'm
going to decide somebody else is going
to take care of it
the more viscerally painful feeling
somebody else's pain is
the more likely you are to wallow and
how painful it all seems
rather than being able to go and act
let alone act in a reasoned rational way
and there's like a fabulous experimental
readout of this
if you're sitting and you're watching
somebody else going through something
painful
and your is to increase your blood
pressure like crazy
you're the sort of person who's been
sitting there saying oh my god
what were this happening to me this
would be so awful i can't take this
anymore i just have to look away
um on the other hand if you could like
empathically note somebody else's pain
and your blood pressure doesn't go up a
lot that's a predictor of the ones who
can actually
act upon the other person's pain rather
than responding to how
painful their own empathic pain is and
what that takes us to is you know on one
hand a version of like getting doctors
uh sort of thick enough of scar tissue
to not feeling the pain they're
inflicting on their patients in order to
do good
um another version of that is sort of a
buddhist detachment about
what empathy is empathy is not because
i am feeling your pain and it is so
painful
empathy is you know it's not a good
thing this is happening to you and i can
do something to alleviate it so
it's self-evident that i should and
that's
subversion which sounds much less
exciting than
heartwarming kumbaya
sort of empathy but if what empathy is
mostly doing
is making you like lick your own
empathic wounds it's
not very useful which brings me to the
other thing that i thought that this uh
discussion brings up which is what what
sort of the actionable
intelligence here how can we use this
view of how we rationalize our decision
making both to make better decisions but
also
to talk other people into changing their
minds
should we try less hard to aim at facts
and reason and logic and and go right
for the gut
or um is it more subtle than that um
unfortunately i don't think it's any
more
horizontal okay um i think in lots of
ways
um if the last four years could be
summed up
as the main take-home lesson for
rational
careful thinkers with a respect for
facts blah blah
one of the things that we've been taught
over these last four years
is you can't reason somebody out of a
stance that they weren't reasoned into
in the first place
if they got to where they are out of
fear
out of anxiety out of resentment out of
envy
out of a sense of being peripheralized
those things like he can't talk to him
to them about how what they're
advocating actually
is going to make things worse for them
you can't reason people out of stuff
that is just
based on the most visceral of emotions
because those emotions are usually
coming from people
who've gotten some crappy deal along the
way
and presumably those people include
ourselves right is there something
that we can take away for our own
decision making like presumably many of
my decisions
which i perceive as perfectly rational
are secretly driven by my anterior
singulator some equivalent uh organ in
my body
yeah and that that's where you get to
like philosophers god help me for
quoting but people like john rawls
who basically said if you're gonna
decide if
you know a moral act is okay or not
um you're not allowed to know who the
actor is and who the recipient is
um right and if it's you in it um
because the second there's a me in it or
someone who reminds me of me
conscious or otherwise yeah all of us
have the same problems all of us
are suffering from uh
making decisions in life that we think
of as highly cognitive that instead
reflect
the tumult of viscera that have gotten
us to this
and it's not just this or that organ in
our brain right i mean you talk in the
book about the importance of hormones of
testosterone
uh oxytocin etc like where our brains
are floating in this bath of chemicals
that have a huge effect on how we behave
and again where we have no idea what's
happening right
um here's okay here's here's one of my
favorite sort of testosterone studies
um where what you see is
you know what does testosterone do what
makes you aggressive
no it doesn't make you aggressive what
testosterone does
is make you more sensitive to cues
that would trigger aggression and you
cues that you have socially learned
so testosterone makes you more rotten
to people who you've already learned
socially you can be rotten to and get
away with
it doesn't make you take on you know
bill gates or something
so it's more subtle than that but it
does perceptual stuff
so there's this long-standing dogma that
testosterone will make people's
analytical math geometric skills better
and you give guys testosterone without
them knowing it
and it doesn't make it better however
they decide they think that they
are performing better than they actually
are
testosterone makes you less accurate
at assessing risk and less accurate at
accepting feedback about your own
performances and it makes you cocky and
bullheaded
that's a very subtle effect because
you're not going to sit there and say
you know i'm feeling real confident
right now and almost certainly that's
because
that's been doing something to potassium
channels and my amygdala
um no you decide why
absolutely your army is going to like be
at their capital within two days
so let's go for it let's invade by all
means
and you can see why um constant exposure
to these kinds of ideas would erode
someone's belief in free will
yeah um and
in some ways where i think
it has to do with the most and all of
this is said
not only am i a free will skeptic
i don't believe there is a shred of
agency that goes into any of our
behavior
so that puts me like out of the lunatic
fringe of the range of
philosophers and neuroscientists
thinking about this
um but in terms of this stuff
where this issue of there's more stuff
going on than we think
subterranean biological forces oh i had
no idea that had anything to do with it
it's out of your control
the realm where it is most important is
when it comes to behaviors that we
judged harshly that we punish
people for that we condemn people for
and the the lesson that i like
pound into the heads of my students over
and over is
500 years ago in virtually every
european country if you had an epileptic
seizure
the best doctors around had a diagnosis
for you as to what caused the seizure
and the seizure was caused because you
were consorting with satan
and they had an absolutely clear
neurological intervention which is to
burn you at the stake
and somewhere along the way people
learned
oh no it's actually a disease
and somewhere along the way they stopped
putting people with epilepsy in
psychiatric hospitals and somewhere
along the way people started developing
laws that distinguished between
who a person is and what a seizure might
do to them
in terms of the ability to drive only
once the meds have kept you seizure free
for a certain length
you sit somebody down today and say wow
can you imagine somebody having a
seizure and you saying yeah that's
because you're sleeping with beelzebub
they'll say oh my god that's ridiculous
that wow people used to believe that
people are going to look back on how we
think of
people with bad self-control people with
an inability to feel somebody else's
problems people who are remorseless
people who are cold-blooded this or that
and it's going to be as misplaced of
attribution that we have now when saying
these are attributes that are deserving
of punishment
as people saying that epileptics were
consorting with satan
and the levels of various hormones in
your body if they do affect your
behavior which they certainly do would
be an example of something
somewhat beyond your control which which
has a big effect on what you do
in the world absolutely so
you know what's happening in your
hormone levels
in the you know hours to days before you
have to make that decision of whether or
not to pull a trigger
whether or not to make this empathic
gesture or whatever
hormones are absolutely playing a role
in it not only in affecting
your behavior but in your ability to
assess the outcome of behavior assess
the feedback from it
that's absolutely the case another thing
as long as we're like still in the
domain
of you know the previous couple of hours
today's before behavior
is all sorts of sensory stuff both the
external sensory world and the internal
one
if you are in pain if you are tired
if you are hungry related to that if you
have low blood glucose levels
you're going to cheat more in an
economic game
you're going to be less charitable
you're going to be less trustworthy
you're going to be less generous you are
going to be more likely to punish
somebody for their norm violations if
you were in pain at the time
or if you're sitting and you're playing
some online economic game and for
a tenth of a second there's flashing up
on the screen
a pair of eyes staring at you where
that's so fast you're barely even
conscious if you saw something
you're less likely to cheat because
you're being
monitored if somebody sits in a room
and there's a bad smell in the room a
smell of garbage permeating in there
people on the average become more
socially
conservative in the decisions that they
make because
they're unconsciously being primed to
feel a little bit disgusted
why am i feeling disgusted says your
implicit
unconscious brain i know it's because
when
those people do that behavior it's wrong
wrong wrong and disgusting there i've
just made a moral decision
and no one is going to sit there and say
oh it's because the room smells badly
and there's neurons in a part of my
brain that processes
gustatory disgust that happens to also
do moral discussed in humans and it
can't tell the difference
so pay no attention to my assessment
just now instead we come up with a
reason why
you know i used to think it was okay
when people do that but it's just
striking me
it's wrong they do that look at
how many hours it has been since a judge
has eaten the meal
and in one extremely well done
influential study
that's the single biggest predictor is
whether somebody a judge is going to
send somebody back to jail or grant them
parole
are you hungry or not i wonder if we
should we could study uh my podcast
episodes versus when i've had lunch and
see whether i
have different i have different
attitudes towards
the guests but i wonder maybe you know i
once heard and i'm not sure whether this
is an urban legend or not but i once
heard that
training as an economist makes you
more uh rationally self-interested and
less altruistic because you're taught
that that's how people behave do you
know if that's a true
thing or just a legend no that's
absolutely the case
it's one of the professions or if you
really want to do it elegantly there's
always the issue
of well maybe the person became an
economist because they were already a
self-interested rational maximizing
machine
you have somebody who's an economist and
either you primed them to talk about
their family life
or you talk prime them to talk about
accounting
and when you make them identify more
with being an accountant
that's when they show more cutthroat
you know game theory play and the same
way
you get somebody to play a version of
the prisoner's dilemma
and if you describe it as the
cooperation game
you get totally different game play out
of most people than if you call it the
wall street game
we all know it's important to exercise
and stay in good physical fitness but
sometimes we're just not in the mood
that moment
or some other times we're in the mood
for some kind of exercise but not some
other kind
and that's why the peloton bike is such
a wonderful invention
the peloton bike is a home exercise
system that is completely
under your control my own favorite
aspect of it is that
you can be in different moods you can
want to exercise but maybe some days
you're thinking
i want to climb mountains well they have
the class for that other days you're
thinking nope i want to go to the club
and dance
they have live dj classes to give you
exactly that feeling
with world-class instructors curated
music and endless fitness variety
peloton has created an unmatched fitness
experience to keep you motivated workout
after workout
you can get one subscription to cover
the whole family and there are classes
for every level
from beginner to super advanced so get
started on your peloton journey go to
onepeleton.com to learn more that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
it does it does make you think but i i
don't want one other thing to get
uh lost too quickly when we were talking
about testosterone
and how you were undermining the sort of
conventional wisdom that it's all about
aggression
and that's something you do over and
over again so there's something you were
taught
is true and it's not quite as simple as
that does that whole
sort of fact that those uh undoings are
so common in this field make us worry a
little bit about
the implications we do draw from
experimental data i mean the brain and
behavior are very complicated things how
do we know when we've gotten it right
yeah especially since you know i don't
know some version of moore's law
every decade the amount of our knowledge
about the brain doubles
just judging by and the number of
papers published that are actually not
true that nobody knows yet
yeah i mean it's why you know all of us
with our
our joe science detective badges and
stuff say we don't find out facts we
have
temporary assessments of how credible we
think our
you know current hypothesis is and we
better be willing to
give it up without a fight if i
contradict it yeah
absolutely okay so we have um
processes in our brain that work on time
scales of what should i say seconds is
it as short as milliseconds how many
tens of milliseconds um yeah
you look at here here's another set of
those incredibly
depressing studies um you stick somebody
in a brain scanner
and you're looking at the amygdala one
of the
like villainous parts of the brain it's
about fear
it's about anxiety it's about aggression
that's interesting you can't understand
the neurobiology
of injuring other people outside the
context of the
biology of being terrified out of your
wits um
but what you see is you know the
amygdala is part of assessing
is this a friendly face is this a
threatening face is what's the emotion
is there no emotion and it does it
really quickly
but a study a finding that has been
replicated a bunch of times now which is
so damn depressing is you stick somebody
in a brain scanner
and you're flashing up pictures of faces
and they're each up for half second or
something
and in your average person you flash up
the face of somebody of a different
race and the amygdala responds
in 60 to 80 thousandths of a second
before you're even consciously aware of
what you're looking at
oh my god that's the most damn
depressing thing on earth and
furthermore
more studies show the more your amygdala
reacts to the face of an other simply
because their skin color is different
the more likely you are to mistake their
cell phone for a handgun
and all sorts of simulation games and
shoot them whereas you're less likely to
do that of somebody of the same skin
color as your own
oh my god that is so depressing that is
playing out in a fraction of a second
yeah is this hopeless no because the
statement that i said before
on the average most people do this
there's exceptions like 30 of people
don't do this and you know all sorts of
stuff that predicts that you're somebody
where
skin color is not going to be a 10th of
a second
us them category by which you divide the
world
and do you know if you can train
yourself to change that in any way
yeah and this is like a whole world of
what to do with our implicit biases
i mean when you look at the people who
don't have those amygdaloid responses
who are they
people who grew up in a racially diverse
neighborhood
okay skin color is not a relevant us of
them divider
my guess is they have their biases
working in some other domain
people who had a close internet
relationship with somebody of another
race along the way
that breaks down you know all of those
are okay
so here's your solution for your
implicit biases go back to your
childhood
again and be brought up in a different
neighborhood that's not very useful
um two things that are though um
and can work fairly rapidly is one thing
that comes out of this whole world of
implicit bias tests the implicit
association test
harvard science department where it
really arose from you could go online
there
and find out just how scarily implicitly
biased you are
about all sorts of stuff testing things
that you cannot gain the system
um but one of the useful things is
when you make people consciously aware
of
the implicit biases that they are
showing does this make the implicit
biases go away
no it makes you put more conscious
effort into
slapping your hand over your mouth
before you say something disastrous or
the equivalent of
the other thing that is very reliably
good at this and this is work that was
pioneered
uh by susan fisk at princeton is
you get somebody in the brain scanner
and this is the circumstance
where there's a picture of the face of
an other
and the amygdala activates oh damn this
is
this is hopeless um if you have primed
the person beforehand
to think of that face as being of an
individual
is this somebody who likes broccoli or
not
is this somebody who likes coke or pepsi
like there's been a whole lot of like
ethnically bloody wars fought over coke
versus pepsi
like totally benign things but force you
to begin to unconsciously process that
face as an individual and you blunt the
amygdaloid response
and that's exactly what it is because
bias
is a heuristic shortcut for us to decide
we know
all about somebody because we think we
know all about the class of somebody's
that we have
attached them to in our heads i mean
maybe that's an important thing
to emphasize both are two important
things one that these biases we have
uh these heuristics uh do serve a
purpose they're not completely brain
dead right
they're actually functional in some way
but number two
they're not determinate either like we
can
that there is some room for system two
and our cognitive capabilities to
overcome that first
initial unconscious response great and
here's
here's an example of like system two in
action
so you take people um
and you're doing the same routine and a
brain scanner you're flashing up
pictures
of faces and you flash up an other race
face
and the amygdala activates and oh god
that really sucks
and the person on some visceral level is
feeling
the aversiveness of that response and
what you see is
in a substantial subset of people i
don't know maybe 50
or so what you see is a second or two
later
there's activation of a part of what is
called the frontal cortex
which is about conscious regulation of
behavior
and of thoughts and of emotions and
every time you feel like telling
somebody
that the dinner they prepared at the
dinner party is the most repulsive thing
you've ever eaten
but you don't say it it's because your
frontal cortex is working properly
so what you see is two seconds later in
about half of people
the frontal cortex activates what is
that that's you
feeling bad that that was your visceral
response that's your
oh my god don't say that or that's not
who i am or that's not who i want to be
who are the ones who activate their
frontal cortex
two seconds after having an implicit
racial bias
people who categorize themselves as
liberals
conservatives don't show that because
there's no dissonance for them
two seconds later they're not finding
anything wrong if that was the visceral
response
so it's not just you know the
conscious sort of system
to jumping in there hey don't think that
way
sort of stuff but the fact that we all
differ as to when we engage
those sorts of conscious uh you know
executive monitoring routines in us
so we have these sort of sub second time
scale responses which we can
uh modulate or even um
override if we want to and then what was
this time scale you associated with the
hormone system with the endocrine system
um you know
hours or a bunch of minutes to a few
days or so
your testosterone levels this morning if
you're male
are going to have something to do with
how likely you are
to decide that somebody with a neutral
facial expression actually has this
threatening facial expression
uh your oxytocin levels this morning
will have something to do with how
trusting you're gonna feel in an
economic game
so playing out in that sort of time
course but that's
just a smidgen of what we have to take
into account
because all we've gotten to is the
biology of the last couple of days that
have brought you to this moment
exactly so let's go back in time further
i mean
let's let's just be ambitious here and
talk about our development uh during our
lifetime right and
one of the favorite factoids that you
laid down to us
in your book is that our frontal cortex
to which we just gave great props for
overcoming our implicit biases uh isn't
even fully formed until we're 25 years
old
so i'm i'm shouting out to all of the
mindscape listeners who are under 25
out there and you know just think of how
smart and cognitive
you're going to be in just a few years
yes
um although as can be seen it's a
double-edged
sword frontal cortex is so cool it does
long-term
planning it does emotion regulation it's
the most recently evolved part of the
human brain we've got more of it than
any other
mammal out there it's totally great it's
the last
part to fully mature some parts of your
cortex are fully wired up when you're a
month old kind of thing
frontal cortex 25 years one implication
of that
is that gets us into trouble when
instead we're 16 instead of 25
because the parts of your nervous system
that are about
thrill-seeking and sensation-seeking and
risk assessment and
conformity to peers driven by stuff like
the neurotransmitter dopamine
that stuff is fully online by around
puberty
and then the frontal cortex is still
fussing with the
like construction manuals for another
dozen years or so
that's why juveniles act in juvenile
ways that's why adolescence is about
these excesses of emotion and all of
that and then
your frontal cortex catches up so you
then say
wow you can like fully maturely wire up
some of your cortex in your first
year of life and your frontal cortex
takes 25 years
is that just a tougher construction
project
are you having to make fancier types of
neurons or there
than the rest of the cortex net it's the
exact same kind of cortex as in the rest
of the brain
why is it a 25-year project because
it better be a 25-year project if the
frontal cortex has the job
of making you do the right thing
when that's the harder thing to do um
it's got to spend 25 years learning what
counts as the harder thing to do
in your culture in your peer group and
you're whatever
i mean we're all taught you know thou
shalt not lie
but here are the circumstances where you
lie and lie if grandma gives you a toy
that you already have tell her you don't
have it
thou shalt not kill but what we actually
mean is you should not kill one of us if
you kill one of them we're more likely
to meet with you and give you an award
afterward
you know it's not trivial
for your cortex to learn what the
hypocrisy is and what the
rationalizations are
of the social world in which you live
and
genes can't specify that by the time
you're 10 months old
that's got to have like a third of your
lifetime
spent learning what the you know
spoken and unspoken rules are of the
world in which you're trying to navigate
and when we talk about the frontal
cortex developing in this way
what exactly does that mean or is it
more neurons coming online or is it
rewiring the neurons that are there
this is this is one of the cool things
about brain development that
like kind of transform your thinking
about it
okay a developing brain a brain that's
doing a good job at
you know getting ahead of the pack just
in time for the sats when you're
a teenager whatever you're just packing
in neurons like crazier packing and
more synapses than anybody else out
there that's exactly the opposite of
what you see
you do not have your most neurons and
most
connections and most complex wiring when
you were 25
you have it when you're about 12 or 13.
oh no
you have more neurons then than what
you're going to have as a young adult
what's adolescence about it is not
generating new circuitry it's pruning
out the circuitry that's sloppy
that's inefficient that's turning out
not to work
your benefit that's not what you're
doing is
cutting away the excess um a fully
mature brain in terms of numbers of
neurons
what it's about is being lean and mean
rather than being
overflowing with its building blocks so
a lot of what's going on in adolescence
is getting rid of the extraneous stuff
and
making the right decision as to what
counts as extraneous
i remember i was struck when i read
about the
neural system of c elegans of the little
round worm right it has uh
whatever it is three hundred and some
neurons you do remember the number
two i think it is three o two three o
two depending on
depending on what gender it is but um
but
so what what struck me was not that
number but the fact that there
was a specific number it was never it
wasn't like 300 plus or minus 10
right uh presumably the human brain
different human brains have different
numbers of neurons we have like 85
billion or something like that or is it
really
can we can we sort of correspond
each neuron to a particular kind of
thing and everyone has exactly the same
wiring at the beginning no absolutely
not
and like one of the best lessons about
how
genes are not deterministic about how
our brains function
is you take identical twins and
at their moment of birth their brains
are already doing gene
regulation differently their metabolic
profiles in a scan are already working
differently
because even if they've been in the same
womb they just had nine months of subtly
different or not so subtly different
fetal environments
and that's got something reducing
variability you know the
the like in some ways
the two key questions for making sense
of any of this like biological
patterning stuff
is why is it that we all have brains
that are similar
and why is it that we all have brains
that have nothing else out there that's
identical
and so that's it i presume you're not
gonna tell us the answer to that
question because this is a very
complicated one and we're learning as we
go
yeah i spend a lot of time
writing about difficult technical
subjects subjects where it's important
to be precise but also to be
alive to not fall into the same cliched
structures over and over again
and that's why i enjoy grammarly premium
grammarly premium is not just about
catching spelling mistakes
or offering you grammar tips it gives
you real-time insights and guidance on
tone on word
choice on clarity so you can communicate
more clearly and confidently
to me the most important thing about
using grammarly premium is that it keeps
you from falling into the same ruts over
and over again
it can make sure your prose is concise
clear and crisp
making new suggestions for vocabulary
words so you don't rely on your old
favorites over and over again
and you can harness the power of
grammarly on every platform with their
desktop editor
browser plugin and mobile apps so
elevate your
writing with twenty percent off
grammarly premium by signing up at
grammarly.com
mindscape that's twenty percent off
grammarly premium
at g r a m a r l y
dot com slash mindscape
but it does for the question of
understanding reasons behind our
behavior
um the lesson presumably is
that there are things that went on
in the womb in childhood as
you know ongoing well past your
childhood well past puberty
that affected what your brain is and how
it's wired and therefore who you are
absolutely and here's like
two studies both of which are
outrageous and should have you like up
screaming about how we can run a society
with facts like this
and ignore them the first one is a
sledgehammer one
which is about 25 of the people on death
row in this country
have a history of concussive head trauma
to their frontal cortex
and when the frontal cortex gets damaged
you don't have somebody who is violently
out of control
because they've got a rotten soul you've
got somebody whose breaks don't work
and talking about punishment and
retribution and
evil and anything like that it makes
little sense there as to talk about a
car whose brakes have failed
um so that one should totally upend
one's thoughts about
like criminal justice the other one is
just as much of a
are you kidding me this is what the
world is like
but it's a more subtle one at first pass
so you look at what hormones have to do
with brain development
and there's a class of hormones that are
secreted during stress
they're called glucocorticoids they do a
bazillion things in your body
and one of the things they do is they
screw up
development of neurons in your frontal
cortex
you have a lot of stress early in life
and your frontal maturation is going to
be impaired sufficiently so
this finding replicated top people in
the field
where by the time a kid is five years
old
if they have been stupid and foolish
enough to have picked the wrong
family to have been born into if they're
being raised in poverty
on the average the levels of
glucocorticoids in their bloodstream are
going to be higher
than kids of higher socioeconomic status
their frontal cortex
is going to be thinner than the more
lucky ses
kids it's going to have a lower
metabolic rate and it's already
predictive
of a frontal cortex later in life that's
going to have a harder job
of doing the tougher thing when it's the
right thing to do
by age five people should be rioting at
the barricades
because early life adversity has a hell
of a lot to do
with how you are sculpting the nervous
system you're going to have for the rest
of your life
as does early life stimulation and early
life love and early life security and
early life insecurity and all this
variance
all of them are affecting how your brain
is constantly being wired and
renovated and upkeep and they all leave
a footprint
and unlike some of the um results that
you've been talking about in some sense
this affirms what you might think right
that how we treat kids
has a very lasting effect on who they
grow up to be
well it affirms how we think about it it
certainly
runs counter to how people thought about
it for a long long time in the 1930s
if you had a kid go into a pediatric
hospital uh well the father would never
be allowed to set foot in there and the
mother would be allowed
in like you know 15 minutes once a week
or so
because mothers aren't useful what they
do is they provide
nutrients and we've got the nursing
staff to do it and
touch and holding and care and comfort
that's and then like 1950s people learn
stuff like that matters and then people
learned like
are you growing up in a neighborhood
being surrounded by
bars or surrounded by libraries
that's going to wire up your brain in
different ways or
like all sorts of stuff people are
constantly
learning much much more subtle factors
in early life
uh are having to do with how the whole
system is being wired up
i think that's fair i think that i'm i'm
sort of taking certain things as just
given and obvious when in fact
even just a few years ago they were not
obvious at all so
good good for you for being a little bit
more accurate there um but let's keep
let's keep going backward in time so we
have our childhood and our subsequent
development
uh we have our hormones and our and our
amygdalas and so forth and there's
stuff going on even before we're born
that presumably we can't be
blamed for but that goes into uh our
genetics and
the rest of our heritage that also
affects how we behave yeah
because environment doesn't begin when
we're born
environment starts as soon as you start
in somebody's womb
and by the time you're born you've just
been nine months having a very
intimate relationship with the
bloodstream of your mother the nutrients
in there the hormones the toxins the
environmental
carcinogens who knows what the whole
long list
and what your fetal life is like
has something to do with how your brain
is wiring up because it's giving some
hints as to what the world out there is
going to be like
the the flagship observation of this is
one
which is just in every textbook out
there and you know we're accustomed to
you learn something about
lab rats and then you learn about it in
monkeys and then maybe you could see the
same thing with humans
this was an observation that started
with humans
uh 1944 uh
germany nazis occupying the netherlands
and during that winter there was an
uprising of the netherlands that was
crushed by the nazis and
as part of the punching for it during
that winter
all of the food in holland was diverted
to germany
and for three months basically everybody
was starving what is known historically
as the dutch hunger winter and like 30
000 people starved to death and
up until that point people had an okay
diet a wartime diet
and then at the other end the allies
came along and liberated
the netherlands and suddenly people go
back to having
you know a decent diet and you've got
three months of starvation
and it turns out if you were a third
trimester fetus
during the dutch hunger winter your body
forever after decided you know what
there's not a whole lot of food out
there so any food i get i'm gonna store
away
right and any salt i get i'm gonna
retain
and what happens is everything else
being equal
60 years later you have almost a 20-fold
increase likelihood
of having diabetes and obesity and
hypertension if you were a second
trimester fetus
that wouldn't happen that's not when
your body was deciding okay how much
food is there out there if you were a
newborn
that doesn't happen either if you were a
second trimester fetus during the dutch
hunger winter
you have a greatly increased risk of
suffering from schizophrenia in
adulthood
if your mother was depressed during the
time that you were a fetus
you have an increased risk of depression
for the rest of your life
because it's got something to do with
how reward pathways in your brain were
wired up
fetal environment is very very relevant
to our notion that environment shapes us
and you know we all differ as to how
lucky or unlucky
our fetal environments were that we
happen to stumble into by chance
and what about uh the environment
environment i mean
for like our ancestors growing up in
different parts of the world different
climates different cultures
to what extent uh do those sort of
differences
in the selection of people from whom
we've drawn our genes
end up affecting us today well what you
see
is like one of the dictums out there is
genes co-evolve with behavior
co-evolve with brains co-evolve with
cultures and they're all influencing
each other
and what you see is some like
really amazing stuff out there i i love
this literature just because
it's one of those where like it's got to
stop you in your tracks with the oh my
god i had no idea biology had something
to do with that
if your ancestors were nomadic
pastoralists wandering deserts or
grasslands with cows or
camels or sheep or something versus if
your ancestors 400 years ago were
farmers
if you were descended into pastoralists
you were much more likely to murder
somebody today over
a perceived honor violation
you were much more likely to i shouldn't
have a clan
vendetta you were much more
you're a descendant of a culture of
honor
people who were pastoralists and then
cultures of honor
how come because if you're a farmer
nobody can come and steal
all your crops one night if you're a
hunter-gatherer they can't come and
steal your rainforest
they can come and steal your cows at
night and as like some bedouins saying
like classic
nomadic pastoralists um if they come for
my camel and take them and i don't do
nothing
tomorrow they're going to come for the
rest of my camels and the day after
they're going to come for my wife and
daughters
what you do is you have maximal
retribution when you think there was an
honorific violation and if you're a
descendant of those cultures
you are more likely to have honor
related
acts of violence if you were a
descendant
in modern china these days of people who
two generations ago
were wheat farmers rather than rice
farmers
rice farming is this huge collectivist
thing
where you have 10 villages that have
been maintaining the same irrigation
system for the last thousand years
and everybody works collectively wheat
farming is much more individualistic
you find wheat farmers up in the north
you find the rice farmers in the
southeast the sort of
monsoon patty rice paddy areas if
your grandparents were wheat farmers
you were more likely to be divorced than
if your grandparents were rice farmers
you're more individualistic you're more
likely to have filed for a patent
if your ancestors lived in a desert
you were more likely to have a
monotheistic religion
if they were from the rainforest you
were more likely to be polytheistic
just lists and lists of these my god
how does this like happen how does what
was going on 400 years ago
translate into things like this because
culture
affects child rearing practices and
child rearing practices
affect the brain you wired up and that
will affect
the cultural practices which you value
and then propagate to the next
generation
and you see stuff like like how's this
for as trivial as it gets
you take mothers from collectivist
cultures and
most of their studies are of people from
southeast asia
where there's a tremendous group
mentality
and you take people from the most
extreme of individualist cultures and
the us
of course are the like poster children
for that
and within minutes of birth mothers from
these two cultures
on the average sing lullabies to their
newborn
at different decibels
[Laughter]
mothers from collectivist cultures sing
softer
than mothers from individualist cultures
and that's just the first step you're
seeing differences between those two on
the average between
how much of each day you're in physical
contact with your kid how
what's the average lag time before you
pick your kid up when they're crying at
what age
you wean them at what age are they
sleeping in a room by themselves
all you're doing from the very first
step there
up until you know in adulthood and
seeing
what your culture is handing out awards
for
every step of the way you are
propagating
the cultural values you were raised with
that were passed on
and that leave an imprint into your
brain and your behavior and your genes
and what you then pass on to the next
generation
well you slipped in there and your genes
so i'm wondering you know
to the extent that these kinds of
behaviors are
uh passed down through societies or
groups of people
i could imagine that's happening either
completely culturally through memes if
you like uh in dawkins's sense
or i could imagine that there's
different selection pressures in
different
parts of the world for different kinds
of genomes right do we are we able to
disentangle that kind of thing
um with a great deal of work
and a great deal of controversy and a
great deal
of people who rush in where angels fear
to tread
mainly because they have some
ideological acts to grow
what you mostly see is if you're
thinking about
genes determining a lot of stuff about
your behavior
you're decades out of data as to the
genetics the behavioral genetics that
you know
over and over and over genes are about
our potentials
genes are about our vulnerabilities
genes are not about our
inevitabilities and you see this
for example okay there's this one gene
variant it's got something to do with
this neurotransmitters serotonin
and there are all sorts of reasons to
think this gene comes in a couple of
different flavors
uh animal studies suggested if you had
this flavor instead of that flavor
you were more likely to be violent and
that's because
the animal studies show that let's study
thousands of people from birth up into
adulthood and track their genetics
and are you indeed more likely to have
had a history of violence as an adult
if you had that scary gene variant
and the answer was yes yes uh oh are we
looking at genetic determinism
the answer was yes comma if and
only if you were abused as a child
in other words genes and environment
interacting and
like the same traits that will give
you like a very well developed frontal
cortex and
with great emotional regulatory
abilities
depending on one setting what that's
going to mean is
you're just going to work on a front
line emt
life saving person around the clock and
suppress all your exhaustion or in
another setting it means that your brain
is going to make you be
really good and disciplined at being
like
a genocidal warlord
i guess for the there's also but there's
also the question
quite closely related to this of looking
at
differences in our ancestors 400 years
ago which is the number you just
mentioned
versus 20 000 years ago um if there were
a difference
400 years ago my bet would be
that that still affected our behavior
today my bet would be that
most of that transmission was cultural
whereas if there's a major difference 20
000 years ago there's sort of more room
for evolution to work and our actual
genomes to change
absolutely and that's getting to the
range i mean dogma used to be
uh 20 000 years that's a blink of an eye
from evolutionary standpoint
20 000 years is enough for significant
changes in gene distributions in
different populations
genes having to do with melanism of skin
color
genes having to do with weather as an
adult you can digest
milk products genes having to do with
your vulnerability to
skin cancer genes that you know just a
whole array of that
genes having to do with developing
modern
capacity for language um those are all
genes that are developed
really fast under a lot of selective
pressure so yeah
that's getting into the time range so
when you begin to look
at you know where evolution has got us
to
the obligatory like soundbite at this
point is
you gotta remember the last 20 years and
even the last 20 000 years or a blink of
an
eye and hominid history we've been
around for a couple of million
and we evolved under circumstances
very different from that thing we
invented like yesterday
which is agriculture and material
culture and we were just
you know hunter-gatherers forever and 99
of our time we evolved into those
circumstances and that makes for a brain
which in many ways is not terribly well
adapted
for the present and if i had to
say the single biggest way in which
that's the case
is the vast majority of human history
we've spent
surrounded by people that we know
and have known for a long time and in
fact are often
third or fourth cousins and it's really
only in the last 10
000 years with like hamlets turning into
settlements turning into
like proto-states kind of thing that
it's possible
for humans to live surrounded by
strangers
and to do something anonymously where no
one will know you did it
for 99 of human history there's no such
thing as doing something where no one
will know that you did it
and all sorts of regulatory control
you know evolved into those
circumstances
i did have uh joe henrik on the podcast
recently
uh who's been talking about the
weirdness of the west and
he has this new theory that uh a lot of
it can be attributed to
the church telling people not to marry
their cousins and that opened them up to
sort of mingling and
free associating with different groups
of people which created western
culture uh is that compatible with the
kind of story you're telling here
absolutely he's great and in fact i was
just about to cite him in the next
sentence
not not that branch of his work but a
related one
there's lots of different kinds of
religions there's lots of different gods
who have been invented out there i don't
know six seven thousand different
religions
and one of the variables is whether or
not
the god or gods your folks have invented
care about what you humans are doing
and what he and a collaborator
university of british columbia sort of
first demonstrated
is in hunter-gatherers all over the
planet
the god or gods they make up have no
interest in human activities
they could care less what humans doing
it's
not until you get people living in large
settlements
it's not until you get societies where
people can
interact anonymously that you start
inventing what are called
moralizing gods gods who are watching
gods who know who've been good for
goodness sake god
punishment because as soon as you get to
a range where you have a society where
people can get away with stuff with
anonymity
you've got to invent supernatural forces
constraint and that's incredibly
important
in terms of making sense of like
the values we have about why are we here
on earth
are we sinful or not are beautiful or
not and is there an afterlife and what
counts is a good life
and all that reflects all sorts of
ecological biological evolutionary
cultural all intertwined influences
that have got you to the point where you
are well i i
think it's one thing to do as you've
already done to sort of
locate a population some number of years
ago
and follow it through time and say that
compared to this other population
they behave differently and their maybe
their genomes are different depending on
the time scales
but then there's another layer we add on
that which is this explanatory story
right
the reason why uh you get honor cultures
from pastoral societies is because
cattle are vulnerable to theft
that that part seems a lot harder to be
scientifically skeptical
about and really get right absolutely
because
uh it's kind of tough to do a 400 year
experiment
on let's take these folks and dump them
in the gobi desert for the next four
centuries whereas these folks go to the
amazon and
let's meet at the end and see how things
you can't do the type of science that
lab scientists respect which is
experimental stuff
you do more descriptive you do
sociological you do
what winds up being the gold standard is
if it winds up being predictive
here is the first time this
hunter-gatherer
culture has been studied and do they
indeed show these traits at a higher
than expected chance do they
you know that's the best you can do and
sometimes that's great
and teleology is something that
like all scientists like to think with
but never like to admit to
um because things happen for a reason
and if you could think what those
reasons are that gives you a lot of
insight
but some of the time you're just making
up just so stories here's why the zebra
got its stripes
here's why most cultures on earth have
male domination here's why
it's natural it got selected for and
yeah you got to be really careful that
notions explanations causal
stories that you've come up with can be
falsified
and are actually supported by data
rather than
being ideological well you said speaking
being ideological maybe there's a
harmful and helpful ideologies i mean
you started out at the beginning by
saying that human beings
uh in some ways have some of the worst
traits uh in the whole animal kingdom
but in some other ways
have some of the best i mean given all
this
better understanding that we have now
about behavior than we ever did
how does this help us become better how
do we how do we turn this into an
optimistic picture for the future of
humankind
well we learn about the ways
in which you're just like every other
animal out there
with the same blueprint and the same
hormones and the same enzymes and the
same transcription
factors and incredible conservation
and we see it's the same parts of the
brain and the same hormones
involved in violent behavior involved in
affiliate of behavior wow we're just
like all the other animals
and what we then have to be trained to
do as well is say
but hey we're secreting the same exact
oxytocin when we're reading about
the pains of the character in a novel
we're reading
that a mother chimp would secrete when
her infant is in
we can do it about stuff that doesn't
really exist
we could do it for movie characters we
could do it for refugees on the other
side of the planet
who we're never gonna meet where we
don't even know what their pheromones
smell
like or you know that we can extend that
we have the basic wiring of violence
of like half the other primates out
there but we could use it to kill
someone whose face we've never seen or
we could use it to kill someone
because they have different notions of
what happens to you after you die
than you do we have the same basic
blueprint lots of the time and then we
use in ways that are totally novel
and i think that's where we have to be
very conscious
of when we're using stuff
that's been around for 20 million years
of primate evolution
70 million years of mammalian
million of vertebrate evolution and
we're using it in a way that just got
invented last
week and to be very on guard on the ways
in which that like will set us off the
rails
right and so the the thing
i think you've said this but it's it's i
can i have trouble say
understanding what other people said
when i have an opinion already that is
very close to that i ended up just
putting in my own words here so
this ability of human beings to
conceptualize
the future especially sort of
counterfactual
hypothetical future scenarios seems to
be
if not unique to humans at least much
better developed in human beings than
elsewhere i've talked to various people
in the podcast including carl fristen
about this and and malcolm mciver and so
is that what you're suggesting we
take advantage of is that our our secret
to making ourselves better
um that's one of the ones um
another one is to be aware
one version of the future is
the certainty that people in the future
are going to look back at us
and be as appalled as we are when
looking at it
the value systems of medieval peasants
so be very cautious before you decide
you know what's going on
um another thing we should be aware of
if if i had to pick the single thing
that is conserved and how our brains are
constructed
that's in line with every other social
animal out there
that is the cause of more human misery
than like one can imagine
it's the fact that like every other
animal out there
we have automatic implicit
you know lightning fast classifications
of people as to whether they are in
us or them and
we have automatic lightning fast
conclusions
that we like the us is a whole lot more
than the themes
we're like every other primate after all
but where are we different we have
multiple us
them categories in our heads at the same
time
and while it may be inevitable
that we as primates make us them
dichotomies
it's incredibly easy to manipulate us
as to which dichotomy seems most
important to us at any given point
and the guy walking towards you on the
street at night who's
uh one of those and scary
and maybe i should be all anxious and
your amygdala is firing like crazy
if the next day you're sitting next to
him in a sports stadium and you're both
chanting the same idiotic chant in favor
of your team
that you'd give up your life for your
brother at arms kind of thing
um we are just like other animals
until the ways in which we are very
different and what culture is often
provided is
ways to manipulate the hell out of us as
to exploiting those uniquenesses
and for better and an awful lot of the
time for worse
you know i just saw a video online uh
one of these nature videos
where a lion a lioness female lion
was hunting and was able to separate out
uh a newborn water buffalo from the pack
so you know a perfect weak little uh
snack to snack
on but then rather than snacking on it
and finishing off its prey the lioness
adopted it started taking care of it and
and the explanation obviously given
after the fact no one interviewed the
lioness but
the idea was well maybe she had just
lost her own cubs
and her maternal instincts overwhelmed
her hunger instincts
and and maybe that's a paradigm for how
you know we can switch back and forth
between different ways of
conceptualizing others
even within the constraints of our
biological responses
yeah because if you work hard enough you
could find the commonalities
oh my god that thing does not look like
simba at all when he was first giving
birth to
but you know still for a buffalo they're
kind of cute
and their forehead is kind of all
rounded and they got a short muslim
oh look at those big eyes bulging out i
just want to take care of this one
because
i'm a periadolescent female and my
hormones are making me all confused as
to who i should feel maternal about
um absolutely and
the minute you can have instances like
that
it's showing that we are not alone in
doing
other animals versions of contributing
money to a conservation group
right to save some other species instead
of our own
let alone members of our species who are
close relatives
so let me close wind things up with a
completely unfair question
okay do you think uh given that
it's very complicated story of why we
make the decisions we do how we behave
like we do all these different causal
factors going all the way back
and you emphasized over the course of
our chat how many of the
experimental findings were kind of
depressing
in one way or the other so do you think
that people would be
better that the world be a better place
if everyone read your book
if everyone knew uh more about
the actual causal factors that go into
our behavior
than they typically do oh man i could
not have asked for a
better question to set me up to try to
flog more
exactly and the answer is no yep
like it wouldn't help if everyone read
like
that book or listen to a lecture about
how the amygdala
develops or some such thing because once
again
most of human misery is not due to
rational decisions most of human misery
is due to rationalized ones
uh again you can't reason somebody out
of a stance they weren't reasoned
to in the first place once again not a
whole lot of human misery
is due to somebody saying it's okay to
rob it's okay to steal it's okay to
plunder
it's due to people who say it's not okay
to do those things
but here's why i'm an exception today
here's why my people are here's why my
background makes me exception
here's why it really doesn't count with
me you know we are
running on the means by which we can
make rationalization
seem rational thanks to our emotions to
such an extent that
i don't know if everyone should go buy
my book and use it as a
that's certainly not going to bring in
world peace well you know i
i want to be more on your side of people
buying your book here i mean
but i don't have any empirical data to
back me up but something makes me think
that if more people were aware
of how much of our everyday behavior was
not completely rational rule-based
cognitive and how much of it was
automatic
visceral driven by heuristics that we've
inherited from thousands of years ago
it would it would cast our decisions in
a slightly different
light i think a lot of people stick to
their guns about their decisions
because they're convinced that they're
rational even if they're not and maybe
sowing a little bit of doubt in that
conviction would be a good thing
um the psychologist josh green at
harvard who stated it really well
that when people say we have a right to
do that
what they're saying is i can only
rationalize why i want to do that i
don't actually have a rational reason
why i can't tell you why i want to do it
but i want to do it so much that i am
going to declare it to be a right
that's exactly a circumstance like this
you know in an even broader sense if you
accept that
we are nothing more or less than our
biology
incredibly complicated biology from one
second ago to a million years ago when
interacting with environment blah blah
blah
if we are nothing more or less than our
biology
and those are biological influences over
which we had no control that brought us
to this point
if you really really really believe that
you could never feel justified in
thinking you are entitled to anything
more than anyone else
because whatever it is that you have
done which you believe
has earned you praise or entitlement you
had nothing to do with
and if you really really believe this
stuff you have no rational grounds for
ever hating anyone
because they didn't have a damn thing to
do with whatever it is they did no
matter how horrific
and hurtful it was and if you really
think those ways
this could be a very different world and
at the same time like i can think those
ways for about three and a half seconds
at a time before
i fall back into the much more ingrained
stuff but if you really believe this
stuff
those are the only conclusions you can
reach
well couldn't you just say um i really
like being a bundle of
uh visceral heuristics so i'm i'm gonna
just
go with it i'm gonna lean in yeah except
you then have to ask so what are the
circumstances that
brought you to the point of liking
bundles of heuristics
fair enough i mean the legal system is
deciding did somebody intend to do that
or not and if they intended to
oh you're in trouble the legal system
never says
where did that intent come from that
came from
the combination of these seven gene
variants this thing that happened during
second trimester
these cultural values during childhood
and the day that they got exposed to
that like toxin when they were 18 and
then got hit in the head
well you know i do appreciate your
uniquely optimistic version
of existential anxiety and dread so
robert sapolsky thanks very much for
being on the mindscape podcast
thanks sean this has been a real
pleasure
[Music]
you